so big box Barcelona tells us a lot more
about what the entities are how they've
affected the rest of the world and also
where we could be going for the next
couple of films welcome to the heavy
spoilers show I'm your host Paul and
this video are breaking down Bird Box
[Music]
[Applause]
the new film has just released on
Netflix and it's got a big ending that
we definitely need to talk about
building off the back of the first movie
from 2018 we learn lots of things in the
film about how the beings operate you
also get an idea of where things could
be going and it's clear that Netflix are
building a bird box Universe it makes
sense too as though that first movie had
mixed reviews it still ended up being a
massive massive hit the bird Box
challenge was everywhere and seeing my
man walk through the streets with GPS on
made me realize we can now take it up a
level and this movie is sort of an
opposite to the first film whereas
that's centered around Sandra Bullock
trying to survive the beings this guy's
working with them played by Mario Cassis
he's someone we've covered on the
channel before and he was absolutely
excellent in the movie the occupant he
was always an actor that I thought was
brilliant at coming across is really
friendly but you could tell he was
someone who had a darker side to him
that's the case here too when we watch
as he infiltrates groups by pretending
to be a lost survivor who can get them
to a generator now initially we believe
that he's joined by his daughter however
we later learned that all's not as it
seems after Sebastian's wife and her
mother died the pair were attempting to
Layla at their apartment but him
throwing a birthday party gave the game
away now in the first movie we were
introduced to a cult that worshiped the
beings unlike Sebastian they attempted
to force people to see them this always
leads to either one of two outcomes with
them either ending their own lives or
being transformed by the experience the
latter happened in the case of Sebastian
with him now being an agent who believes
he's working for God another culture
named the Sears and them they're the
right hand of the Lord and thus they
carry eyes on their hands like some evil
David Blaine outside of Daredevil and
Kane from John Wick they're the only
people who stand a chance in the real
world as in the land of the blind the
one-eyed man is King now we discovered
that after the birthday party the pair
were grabbed by the cold and Sebastian's
daughter Anna sadly died Sebastian was
then greeted by a vision of her and this
manifestation of his child guides him
through the Wasteland in the end though
it's revealed that she's simply one of
the beings infecting his his mind so
that he'll go out and help out the
entities now for the next part of the
video I want to discuss my theories on
what they are and this will hopefully
explain a number of different things
describe as being Quantum beings there's
a lot that we can take from these and
they clearly appear differently
depending on the onlooker from what I
can grasp they sort of work on the same
principles as schroding as cat and in
case you don't know that's basically a
big thought experiment in it a cat is
placed into a box with a hazardous
chemical a butcher in it yeah but inside
the box there are tiny electrons that
could knock the chemical over and in
spilling this it would kill the cat
until the cat is observed though we
don't know whether it's alive or dead
and thus it exists in two states at once
it's only upon observing it that the
outcome is perceived and this is sort of
seen as being the same as the beings too
they may not have an actual form and
it's only upon being observed that they
actually take one now due to Sebastian
being religious to him they seem like
Seraph Angels which in the Bible are the
highest ranking Celestial beings in the
hierarchy of Angels According to some
accounts their beauty is so great that
only God can look at them which of
course ties into the beings in the film
now in the Bible they're often used to
Signal purification and they sometimes
appear before earthquakes and tsunamis
back then people obviously didn't have
the scientific equipment to measure
seismic activity and stuff so natural
disasters were choked up as being
brought on by God's divine presence you
can see how Sebastian will get wrapped
up in that too and his attachment to
religion is of course murdered in the
seers upon their victim's death we can
even see what looks like their Spirits
floating up to the skies and you can see
how Sears would believe that this was
divine however what I actually think is
that it's aliens
nah I think whatever they are they
clearly aren't Angels but rather they're
using that as a way to manipulate those
Akon in fact it's the same way in which
they manifest as Sebastian's daughter
and I believe that they use
hallucinogenic Visions to manipulate
their prey and followers able to tap
into the minds of those that gaze upon
them they likely appear in one of two
ways now those that die are likely shown
something so horrific that it makes them
instantly want to end their own lives
however it could also be summing out
leads them into doing it through the use
of something that they love after the
bus crash we can hear a child's voice
calling out to a woman and this
eventually leads to her putting her head
into a tire clearly reading someone's
mind they can appear unaware that either
torments them or trick someone into
believing that they're on their side
this is the case with Sebastian as they
appear as both angels and his deceased
order which makes him believe that he's
on a just cause when we look at it the
beings appear exactly like Anna does and
the penin of the Angel lady ends up
giving her now I actually think that
these beings are something that humans
can't comprehend and thus our sheer
misunderstanding of them makes them take
a sin form to us however I think that
these beings can also tap into one's
memories and through their knowledge of
a person's fears and desires they can
appear to them like that this either
gets them to instantly in their own
lives or subscribe to the channel and
work alongside them to help people open
their rise now I believe that these
Quantum beings are actually
inter-dimensional creatures and they're
not actually part of our reality this is
why they can't physically interact with
their victims and they instead have to
use the Sears as where to go and touch
people eyes make up a big part of the
film symbolically and you of course have
to look at the creatures in order for
them to kill you they also appear on the
hands of the seers and they also get
drawn on the foreheads too this happens
throughout the film and Sebastian even
comes across people tied to a bus with
an eye on their forehead this has
certain symbolism to it and when we look
at spirituality this is psychically
described as being a third eye it's
normally depicted as being on the
forehead because it goes beyond ordinary
side and helps the person to see an
altered state of perception this can
provide perception beyond what we can
see normally and this may symbolize them
being extra dimensional now one of the
main reasons that they gave Dr Stranger
there I was so that he could see other
dimensions and stuff like this has been
a big thing in fiction now we'll talk
later on about how the Sears are immune
but the beings clearly realize that they
can't kill them they'll say instead use
the Visions as a way to manipulate them
into opening the eyes of those that
refuse to look now where the victim
Souls flow up to we don't know but I
think it would be wild if there was a
spaceship collecting them in space
ships have traveled millions of light
years to get here obviously we're still
early days but they clearly have
ulterior motives and are desperate to
wipe us out no matter the cost now
Sebastian struggles with his mission
when he comes across a camp who has a
little girl in it just like his daughter
Anna name Sophia she only speaks German
and Sebastian's the only person they've
come across who can also speak the
language he grows attached to her
throughout the film and even gives her
on his pendant which shows that he's
clearly starting to care for her
alongside her as Claire played by
Georgina Campbell and you might
recognize her as appearing in Barbarian
slowly the group are taken out one by
one and it'll lead to just Sebastian
Sophia and Claire surviving early on
Sophia talks about what happened with
her mother and how the pair was split up
she stated there was a radio message put
out that said there was a safe place up
the mountain which is accessible by
Barcelona's poor cable car or any of the
mad's actually been over before and some
of the commune in the first film it's
sort of seen as a sanctuary elevated
surrounded by walls and only accessible
by the cause it's been easy to seal off
and keep protected so after laying this
they decide to head out and Sebastian's
accepted in the group acting like a wolf
in sheep's clothing that metaphor of a
sheep of course has ties to religion as
well and Sebastian could be seen as
someone who's abandoned the flock when
it comes to the Sears they act as his
enemy too and he even questions whether
he's actually a Shepherd or in fact the
wolf I did appreciate how there was this
biblical subtext that surrounded it all
and there's definitely a lot of things
that he can pull from it in the end
Sebastian slowly gets away from the grip
that the beings have on him and he goes
back to humanity instead of sticking
with the visions of his Torah it all
goes down after the truth comes out
about Sebastian and though he gets you
up a hand he refuses to remove the
blindfold from Sofia realizing that he
was a grieving and broken man because of
his daughter's death he decides to
defend the pair from the Sears as they
race to the cable car station Claire and
Sophia are under the top while Sebastian
faces up against the Sears on the ground
but he's not the only one that's trying
to take them out stalked by one of the
beings they have to take a leap of faith
on one of the cars and this allows them
to then Journey up the mountain
meanwhile Sebastian dies impaling
himself in the priest and it stops
Clarence of fear from being followed now
he we get a moment where his daughter
seemingly hugs his chest and this
appears to be the spirit of the real one
rather than one of the beings the guy
also gets a golden light on his face and
potentially this means that he actually
got to go to heaven either way at this
point Claire and Sophia reached the
sanctuary which is where we learn a lot
of things Sophia finds her mother here
and we also see what the Army's been up
to now it turns out that the reason the
Cs have immunity is because they're all
victims of grief and Trauma which is
altered their blood work and thus their
perception of the world due to the way
that the beings operate they need to
rely on someone's perspective in order
to make them act out and being able to
control this will then leave them
powerless Sebastian watching his
daughter dying cause extreme grief
within him and thus this is how he ended
up gaining that immunity withdrawing the
blood of the sea as they've been running
tests and have so far managed to make
rats survive for 48 seconds before it
proves too much however it shows that
they have found a way to survive the
creatures and I think that's gonna be
the next step of where things go in the
end we see them carrying out for their
ass with one of the creatures contained
behind a locked door and it's lucky that
they'll eventually find a cure now I
can't see this being How the Universe
goes forward and we actually have a
rough idea of the plans at Netflix hap
they've said that if the movie's
successful in several other local
language spin-offs will be put into
production and in the end we could get a
bird box Universe it's also likely that
we'll be getting a direct sequel to the
first film and there was actually a
follow-up novel released in July 2020
titled Mallory this picks up several
years after the events of the first film
with the titular character and her
children still living at the sanctuary
however a woman there ends up going mad
and Mallory and the kids end up fleeing
Into the Wilderness now it's hypothesize
that the powers of the beings have
advanced to the point that they no
longer need you to look at them in order
for them to infect you the woman who
went mad was actually blind and thus
this is thought of being the next stage
now after a major time Jump we could of
the kids in their teenage years and also
learn Mallory's taking two new kids
under her wings living out in isolation
they sort of question well whether the
blindfold frees them or if it in fact
just keeps them prisoner now whether
they end up adapting this is another
thing entirely and instead I think the
news of a cure will end up spreading
worldwide I think this will be something
that Mallory learns about in bird box
too and she could use this as a way to
combat the creatures we might then get
worldwide films where the the entire
survivors of Earth come together and I
could see them potentially fighting this
threat or at the very least gaining some
form of immunity there will always be
dangers but it could act as a way to
combat what's going on and at least help
them survive once a creature comes in
now as are my thoughts on the film I
actually really got into this early on
when I realized that they were flipping
the script I think this could have run
into just being a repeat of the first
movie but they've Twisted things enough
for at least me to find it interesting I
also like that they touched upon the law
of the creatures more and actually
Advance the universe instead of just
keeping things where they were that
would have been so easy to do especially
in a spin-off so Props to those guys for
keeping things moving unfortunate
actually I do feel the plot gets a bit
pedestrian come the middle of the movie
and it does kind of drag for for that
middle section I think they could have
cut things down to help with the pacing
but you know I wasn't avidly against the
movie in the end I think it's a
serviceable spin-off and though I don't
think scorses he's going to be calling
it the height of Cinema I personally
enjoyed it I am interested to see where
things go and this actually made me want
to go back and watch that first movie
again so yeah in the end Bird Box
Barcelona it's not gonna it's probably
well it probably will change the world
because everyone will be doing Bird Box
challenges again but I I don't think
it's gonna you know win loads of people
around that weren't interested in this
concept but yeah in the end it did feel
serviceable I'm scoring it a 7 out of 10
and maybe dropping down to a six but you
know it depends if I watch it again and
find it even better always either way
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
movies so drop them in the comment
section below and also while you're
there please hit the thumbs up if you
want to support the channel as a member
of the spoiler Society then please click
the join button below and as a thank you
you'll get early access to videos every
week it goes such a long way to helping
us out I can't believe how many of you
guys are supporting us and being honest
with you it really really means the
world to me now if you want something
else to watch we've got a breakdown of
Mission Impossible 7 on screen right now
so if you left that movie feeling
confused then that's the breakdown for
you we talk about the ending all the
twists and turns and what's happening
next time so yeah definitely head over
after this without the way huge thank
you for taking through the video I've
been poor and I'll see you next time
take care peace